hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today as you can tell we're unboxing
something very exciting and I actually
don't know what's in here I mean I know
what's in here there's a Vitamix blender
inside but which one inside is the
question because I have absolutely no
idea as of you who have been here for
quite a long time no I like to make
things in the blender and I like to make
things in the blender that you probably
probably should stop bro I'm chopped the
Vitamix reached out and said hey we've
got some new blenders we'd like to send
you one and guess what everyone inside
here never cut towards yourself but you
know I shouldn't do that there's a note
I've seen we hope that you enjoy your
new machine we can't wait to see what
you make ah I can't wait either
oh I'm saving that I want this it'll
still last that is definitely it I can
be a testament of that because the
things that I have done my old one this
is going to match my matte black mixer
now like I feel like and I have to take
some cooking classes so that I can put
all of these things to use this is what
I need because I had one of the rubber
top and I kept putting in the dishwasher
and I completely warped and destroyed it
well it fit on I should not put that
doomed that's the stupidest thing that I
could have ever even possibly thought of
doing there are extremely sharp blades
in here and if I would have put that on
my head I would have cut myself a little
book of some recipes start here choose
one liquid choose one green and she's to
fruit like I think that's something I
could do oh yeah
this is big wow this is like heavy duty
I'm gonna go tell her my entire house
high-performance blender or it says your
adventure oh wait no no no no your
adventure oh wait I think the first
thing that I'm going to make is a frozen
pizza smoothie shuffle this in there
this looks a little bit smaller I'll use
the small people so I feel like do an
update or something just connect a Wi-Fi
like do I need to be connected to the
Internet pull men think super high-tech
put you on here this is a huge huge
that's not so many different settings in
my previous one this is an all digital
display got these cute little buttons
that I can just push that I want to make
a milkshake to bring all the boys to the
yard
another boy Scott and they're like
that's what my question I'm assuming
that's a jelly button and this is a wash
wash button is probably my favorite
because you can actually just put hot
water a little bit so push the wash
button and my job here is done
so you really shouldn't put this in the
dishwasher like I've done in the past
because I didn't Sakura TV and I really
want to test this thing out I'm going to
try to blend this frozen pizza which I
feel like should be a pretty easy thing
I'm going to get some water because you
never want to just blend just something
dry yeah there's some water in there to
make it all happen so one of the tips
that I've learned the hard way is you
always want to put in
[Music]
the wet ingredients first especially
when you're blending now will the pizza
blend it's a question and I'm going to
remember that show they probably still
make youtube videos well it's like they
blend iPhone they blend everything we're
going to try to just blend a frozen
pizza like that's pretty basic pretty
well huh
I might put a little more water in just
gen-y some things up a little
this new lid is incredible I'm so
excited about this I might start making
myself some nice movies and the morning
mist clips on we're going to have any
accidents any longer which is
unfortunate because they are always
quite funny so there's no pizza option
so I think I'm just going to pick the
milkshake and I'm going to bring it to
the yard ready
probably Paul huh yep I'm gonna give a
nice haul moment it's moving around
I think this calls for our jammer get
quite safe a professional name but I'll
add a little more liquid oh my dear
sweet sweet treat smells very nice
milkshake skew a little pulsing oh let's
put the lid back on Justine I love pizza
that's it this is blended look I mean
smells fantastic and absolutely smell
delicious
[Music]
I'm salivating a little bit because I
feel like I'm gonna throw up because
this looks so disgusting but I have to
try it I have tried my beginning okay
it doesn't age with virus and you think
it might taste it's the consistency it's
doesn't think it's bad it's just a
little bit wet Michael and if you went
like I think it's coming out my eyes now
it's good Oh God oh let's do the cleanup
routine slides up from hot water in here
when will this open and I'm not really
sure how much but that looks it looks
good let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
outfit she's clean rinse it out and you
should be good to go
guys well thank you so much for watching
this is a pretty exciting and do you
know what this means I'm sure if you've
been with me for quite a while you know
exactly what this means this means more
unnecessary baking videos using a
blender when I probably should it let me
know if anything else cool that you guys
have been absolutely loving lately leave
it in the comments below or feel free to
send me a tweet I'll see you in my next
video Cheers
[Music]
you